jannis ich habe gehört du machst hat mal
wieder ein eigenes genre ja endlich und
mit großer freude und worum geht's es
geht eigentlich um die geschichte der
philosophie und im einzelnen frage ich
will hier vieles oft hat heute noch für
dich eine bedeutung
gut dann will ich sagen weil ich heute
mein zuhause und darauf dass du dann
wieder material abliefert ja bitte und
die episode ist möglich dank wer steht
in die länge kamera und mit ihm gehen
wir jetzt los und zwar zuerst die
kastanienallee rauf und runter und dann
gehen wir zu der humboldt universität wo
wir die möglichkeit die weil die in die
chance haben menschen zu treffen die mit
der philosophie was zu tun haben im
gegensatz zu mir damit sagen
dann sind man passau leute es bis dann
[Musik]
und zwar welche philosophen haben für
sie heutzutage noch eine bedeutung
gekannt
ja die beiden und warum ja weil sie
versuchen auf ihre weise so die welt zu
erklären zu ergründen weiter auf sehr
unterschiedliche weise
ich neige eher zu hegel aber ich finde
sie sehr interessant wir haben alles
werte stark durch darf also den
kategorischen imperativ zum beispiel
finde ich schon sehr sinnvoll
das ist ja handel steht so dass die
maxime deinen freund grundlage für eine
allgemeine rechtsprechung kennt und
werfe ich in der schule immer
eingetrichtert bekommen
vor meinem ethiklehrer und das macht
schon winzig aber sonst finde ich ist
jeder im grunde auch vermissen den
philosophen jeder philosophiert ja übers
leben vor
welche philosophie ich will meine eigene
philosophie in unserem alltag gehört
sich das ja wir haben schon aufgehört
bücher zu lesen die schreiben wir selber
ja die frage heute ist welche vieles
offen haben für dich heutzutage noch
eine bedeutung wäre da vielleicht
foucault natürlich boris roessler sie
sagt zb auch aber andererseits sah mich
für kulturanthropologie an der
humboldt-universität kurzem zum beispiel
michael tsokos frankreich und vier
bordelle und natürlich dann auch
heiliger und kanten sehr bedeutend wie
kommst du klar mit heiliger und kantinen
die dienen die leute kann man nicht
lesen doch jetzt ist er sehr anstrengend
aber es gibt ja zum glück in der
universität auch sehr gute dozenten die
anders näher bringen und ganz die
sekundärliteratur die das dann auch
haben wenn sie komisch irgendwie
verarbeiten kann und ist die welt
motivieren oder geistig das ist auch
eine frage des standpunkts genauso wie
die frage was im freien willen
für mich ist sie immer ein bisschen
geistig welchen vieles offen haben für
die ich heute noch eine bedeutung
also ich kann auch also wie viel spaß
beim lesen
aber die klassische und klassik sich da
sich zähne auszubeißen nicht etwas
unglücklich dass mir versprechen wer
interessante jessica helga überhaupt
nicht kommen sie noch fragen ja noch
mehr mehr ich will noch mehr wissen und
lesen die geschichte der philosophie ab
und zu ja ich unterrichte ich lasse sie
nicht gehen bleiben sie hier ich musste
ja und weil wie es mit ihrer
lebensphilosophie meine
lebensphilosophie meiner
lebensphilosophie ist das leben so viel
wenn wir nicht so genießen wie machen
sie als wir genießen sie das ich
versuche so viel wie möglich so zu leben
dass ich immer was ich mir nicht denken
muss ich habe einen tag vergeudet das
ist sehr schön wo kommen sie her aus
wien und heute ist die frage und welche
bedeutung hat für sie noch die alten
philosophen eine sehr groß weil ich bin
buchhändler und wir verkaufen die und
wir haben auch einen philosophischen
festival aus dem allgäu demnächst wo ich
herkomme haben wir gerade den richtigen
getroffen also ich habe zufällig einen
buchhändler gehört kaufen der sogar eine
art philosophie treffen organisiert oder
ja ein philosophie festival war müssen
wir uns anmelden in oberstdorf ist es
ist das zentrum und der verein heißt
philosophie in den allgäuer alpen
ja das was ich schon immer wissen wollte
wer ist eigentlich für dich der wichtig
die frisur oder lasse ich mich anders
formulieren welcher philosoph hat dein
denken geprägt
eine ganze reihe fürs offen haben mein
denken geprägt und zwar angefangen von
thales aus me leck mich ob ich die
deutschen namen da richtig parat haben
und an sokrates und das hotel ist ein
paar minuten und doch wer durch brüche
nietzsche natürlich ganz ganz stark aber
auch kant aber auch im negativen sinne
auch marc sehr lange zeit sehr intensiv
die hast aber für all dieses unglück was
er auf die welt gebracht hat doch weil
er hat zum verbrecher des gedacht alle
denken das war es in guter mensch die
sich gutes gedacht habe das stimmt nicht
er war schon dabei zu denken dass wir
zehn prozent der gesellschaft ab knall
müssen um bringen müssen um sie dann
wird man verändern zu können
um diesen weg den er theoretisch
angefangen hat am aldi verbrecher mit
hitler mit stalin mit mao tse tung mit
all den anderen sind dann weiter
gedanken was muss man schon wissen immer
neue kann das wichtigste für mich und
warum er lästert ein ziemlich langweilig
chr ziemlich langweilig aber der hat die
grundlagen für all unsere tollen
freiheitlichen sachen gelegt und ich
sage immer man sollte es nicht vergessen
ist es weiterentwickelt worden und gibt
sicherlich wie weiteres aber ohne ein
anfang gibt keine weiterentwicklung
nitze segelschiff und warum welche
lebensregeln hatte und etwas
hinterlassen hat nachdem wir jetzt noch
leben und existieren für mich foucault
auf jeden fall und erzählen sie ganz
kurz was kriegt natürlich habe ich die
namen gehört aber haben
ich habe mich nie mit ihm wirklich
beschäftigt sie ganz kurz ok focus
spricht für übergriffe einer mentalität
und das bedeutet so viel wie das wir
normen von außen schon wahrnehmen und
auf dem man das gefühl haben dass wir
das
also das was die norm und vorschreiben
eigentlich aus uns heraus selbst tun
also dass das sozusagen verschleiert
wird das für uns selber einreden sie
wären autonom und wir würden alles
selber entscheiden dabei kommt es
eigentlich von außen und welche lösung
haben wir da wie können wir uns da
springen die selbstständige ich weiß
nicht ob er eine anbietet ich glaube man
kann sich das erst mal bewusst machen
und darüber nachdenken viel zu januar
wird wieder da hast du antworten
bekommen wir haben sehr wunderschöne
antworten bekommen was war die beste
antwort die beste antwort war
ich habe einen menschen getroffen der
einen philosophen festival veranstaltet
das gibt's ja wohl nichts und nächstes
jahr sind wir mit der generellen mit dem
markt dabei nur leute die sind wie janus
sie haben es um seinesgleichen ja früher
habe ich zu wenig zum rock festivals
gefahren und jetzt ist die zeit für die
fest für die philosophen festivals aber
geschossen wird genauso sehr gut jetzt
wollen wir natürlich von euch wissen was
ist der wichtigste philosoph oder die
wichtigen philosophische richtung in
eurem leben gewesen interessiert euch
über philosophie oder habt ihr damit
weniger am hut schreibt uns dass man die
kommentare und vielleicht möchtet ihr
auch mit genesis philosophie festival
fahren
meldet euch bei uns ja maßgeschneiderte
philosophen wandel geht gleich nach
hause und schneidet dieses video in der
zeit werde ich an übungen arbeiten wie
ihr wisst jede woche gibt es übungen in
verschiedenen stufen mit diesen übungen
könnt ihr euer deutsch vertiefen und zb
das vokabular noch einmal wiederholen
was für heute gehört haben und wenn ihr
die auch bekommen möchte die gibt es
jede woche in unserer patchen community
den link findet ihr hier
und wenn ihr mitglied werden dann könnt
ihr dort ja übung machen vokabeln lernen
fragen stellen alles mögliche danke dass
sie dabei waren wir gehen hier in den
mehreren spielen wollt schreibt uns und
abonnieren könnt ihr uns auch bis
nächste woche klar